.
LET'S HAND IT OVER TO JAKE
TAPPER AND "CNN TONIGHT."
>>> WELCOME TO "CNN TONIGHT."
I'M JAKE TAPPER IN WASHINGTON.
AND TONIGHT WE WANT TO LAY OUT
SOME NEW ALARMING DETAILS ABOUT
RUSSIA'S BRUTAL WAR AGAINST THE
UKRAINIAN PEOPLE.
WE'RE GOING TO START WITH NEW
WARNING SIGNS OF THE KREMLIN
CONSIDERING THE USE OF A
TACTICAL NUCLEAR WEAPON.
U.S. OFFICIALS BELIEVE SENIOR
RUSSIAN GENERALS HAVE DISCUSSED
HOW AND WHEN TO DEPLOY ONE.
THERE IS DEBATE ON HOW SERIOUSLY
TO TAKE THIS INTELLIGENCE.
IS IT FURTHER SIGN OF RUSSIAN
DESPERATION AND CAUSE FOR REAL
CONCERN?
OR ARE THESE DISCUSSIONS BEING
TAKEN OUT OF CONTEXT?
ON CNN EARLIER TONIGHT, TOP
WHITE HOUSE SECURITY OFFICIAL
JOHN KIRBY REACTED TO THE LATEST
U.S. INTELLIGENCE REPORT.
>> THERE'S LOTS OF LEVELS OF
CONCERN, OF HEIGHTENED CONCERN,
ABOUT WHAT'S GOING ON IN UKRAINE
RIGHT NOW THAT GIVES US CAUSE TO
CONTINUE TO CLOSELY MONITOR AS
BEST WE CAN RUSSIA'S NUCLEAR
CAPABILITIES.
>> NOW THE INTELLIGENCE REPORT
SAYS THAT VLADIMIR PUTIN WAS NOT
PART OF THESE TALKS.
BUT PUTIN HAS PUBLICLY DANGLED
THE PROSPECT OF USING A NUCLEAR
DEVICE FOR MONTHS.
TODAY RUSSIA'S MINISTRY OF
FOREIGN AFFAIRS PUT OUT A
STATEMENT PERHAPS TO TRY TO EASE
FEARS THAT REMAINS KREMLIN
POLICY TO ONLY USE NUCLEAR ARMS
IN A DEFENSIVE RESPONSE
DECLARING, QUOTE, A NUCLEAR WAR
CANNOT BE WON AND MUST NEVER BE
FOUGHT.
ABIDE BY A DEAL TO ALLOW VITAL
GRAIN EXPORTS FROM UKRAINE SAFE
PASSAGE IN THE BLACK SEA, WHICH
WOULD BE A WELCOMED REVERSAL TO
THOSE WHO FEARED A GLOBAL HUNGER
CRISIS.
UKRAINE AND RUSSIA ACCOUNT FOR
NEARLY A THIRD OF THE WORLD'S
WHEAT EXPORTS.
HERE'S THE U.S. AMBASSADOR TO
THE UNITED NATIONS ON CNN THIS
MORNING.
>> CLEARLY RUSSIA WAS FINALLY
CONVINCED THAT THEY NEEDED TO
CONTINUE THIS.
THEY CAN'T STAND IN THE WAY OF
FEEDING THE ENTIRE WORLD.
>> BUT PUTIN IS ALSO THREATENING
TO PULL OUT OF THAT DEAL, AGAIN,
IF HE FEELS UKRAINE USES ACCESS
TO THE BLACK SEA FOR ANY
MILITARY PURPOSES.
NOW, THESE ANNOUNCEMENTS WOULD
BE WELCOMED IF YOU TAKE THE
KREMLIN AT ITS WORD.
BUT WE HAVE ALL WITNESSED SO
MANY MOMENTS WHERE THE KREMLIN
SAYS ONE THING AND DOES THE
EXACT OPPOSITE, WHETHER
INSISTING THEY WOULD NEVER
INVADE UKRAINE, OR THEY WILL
ALLOW SAFE PASSAGE FOR REFUGEES
AND WON'T HARM THEM AT ALL, OR
PROMISING TO ALLOW WHEAT EXPORTS
AND GOING BACK ON THAT PLEDGE.
WE'RE NOT CONFIDENT THAT WILL BE
THE CASE.
WHAT WE ARE CONFIDENT ABOUT IS
THE CONTINUED RUSSIAN ATROCITIES
WE'RE SEEING ON THE GROUND IN
UKRAINE.
TONIGHT CNN'S CLARISSA WARD IS
GOING TO BRING YOU NEW EVIDENCE
OF THESE HORRORS, AS SHE FOLLOWS
INVESTIGATORS WHO ARE TASKED
WITH LOOKING FOR CASES OF RAPE
AND OTHER SEXUAL VIOLENCE INSIDE
KHERSON, A REGION RECENTLY FREED
FROM RUSSIAN OCCUPATION.
IT SADLY REINFORCES WHAT A
UNITED NATIONS INDEPENDENT TEAM
FOUND, RAPE AND TORTURE.
SOMETIMES THE VICTIMS WERE
CHILDREN, SOME AS YOUNG AS FOUR.
AND AT TIMES FAMILIES OF THE
VICTIMS WERE FORCED TO WATCH.
THE HEAD OF THE HUMAN RIGHTS
ORGANIZATION WARNS THAT MANY OF
THESE CRIMES WILL SURELY GO
UNPUNISHED, NO ACCOUNTABILITY.
BUT HERE IN THE U.S., THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT CREATED A NEW
DIVISION IN JUNE TO INVESTIGATE
THESE RUSSIAN ATROCITIES, THESE
WAR CRIMES.
AND THERE'S NOW A BIPARTISAN
PUSH TO CHANGE U.S. LAWS SO THAT
IT WILL BE EASIER TO PROSECUTE
RUSSIANS FOR THESE HORRIFIC
DEEDS IN U.S. COURTS SHOULD
THESE RUSSIANS EVER ENTER THE
UNITED STATES.
NOW, IT'S HARD TO BELIEVE, BUT
THERE ARE SOME IN RUSSIA WHO
ACTUALLY ARGUE THAT PUTIN HAS
NOT BEEN BRUTAL ENOUGH.
AND WE WANT TO SHINE A LIGHT
TONIGHT ON A MERCENARY ARMY THAT
IS EMERGING FROM THE SHADOWS.
LET ME INTRODUCE YOU TO -- A
RUSSIAN OLIGARCH BEST KNOWN AS
PUTIN'S CHEF, AND FOR GOOD
REASON.
HIS RESTAURANTS AND CATERING
COMPANY AND HOSTED DINNERS
ATTENDED BY PUTIN AND OTHER
WORLD LEADERS.
BUT HE IS ALSO KNOWN FOR SERVING
UP BODIES.
JUST A FEW WEEKS AGO, PRI GOES
YAN ADMITTED TO FINDING THE
WAGNER GROUP IN 2014.
YOU MIGHT HAVE HEARD WHISPERS
ABOUT WAGNER.
IT USED TO BE A PRIVATE
MERCENARY GROUP THAT OPERATED IN
THE SHADOWS.
BUT IN RECENT YEARS, CNN HAS
TRACKED WAGNER OPERATIVES IN
UKRAINE, MOZAMBIQUE, SYRIA.
>> THIS IS A STRAIGHTFORWARD
BARGAIN.
THEY PROVIDE THE WEAPONS AND IN
RETURN THEY GET ACCESS TO THE
COUNTRY'S NATURAL RESOURCES.
AND IN THE PROCESS HOPE TO
REASSERT THEMSELVES AS A MAJOR
PLAYER IN THIS REGION.
>> THE WAGNER GROUP HAS A
GRUESOME REPUTATION AND IS
LINKED TO ANY NUMBER OF HUMAN
RIGHTS ABUSES INCLUDING TORTURES
AND BEHEADINGS.
TOP U.S. OFFICIALS HAVE
CONSISTENTLY WARNED ABOUT THE
WAGNER GROUP'S BRUTAL TACTICS.
>> POOR GOVERNANCE, EXCLUSION
AND CORRUPTION, INHERENT WEAK
DEMOCRACIES MAKES THEM --
FOREIGN INTERFERENCE.
THAT INCLUDES THE KREMLIN-BACKED
WAGNER GROUP WHICH EXPLOITS
INSTABILITY TO COMMIT ABUSES
WITH IMPUNITY.
>> RUSSIA'S WAR ON UKRAINE HAS
THRUST WAGNER INTO THE
SPOTLIGHT.
UKRAINIAN OFFICIALS ESTIMATE AT
LEAST 5,000 WAGNER MERCENARIES
ARE FIGHTING ALONGSIDE RUSSIAN
FORCES IN UKRAINE.
WHERE ARE THEY FINDING SO MANY
SOLDIERS?
WELL A CNN INVESTIGATION FOUND
THAT WAGNER IS RECRUITING
MURDERERS AND DRUG DEALERS FROM
PRISONS WITH A PROMISE THAT IF
THEY SURVIVE THE WAR IN UKRAINE,
THEY WILL BE GRANTED SHORTER
SENTENCES OR EVEN AMNESTY.
NOW, THESE AREN'T FORMER
SOLDIERS WHO HAPPEN TO BE
IMPRISONED.
THEY ARE MEN WHO ARE HARDENED,
BRUTAL CRIMINALS.
THIS IS WHAT ONE PRISONER TOLD
CNN'S NICK PATON WALSH.
>> IF IT'S REAL, THEN I AM ALL
FOR IT.
IT'S EITHER BE IMPRISONED FOR
NINE YEARS OR GET OUT IN SIX
MONTHS IF YOU ARE LUCKY.
BUT THAT'S IF YOU ARE LUCKY.
>> PRONEGOTIATION HIMSELF
RECENTLY DID SOMETHING THAT
WOULD HAVE ONCE SEEMED
UNFATHOMABLE.
ACCORDING TO OFFICIALS, HE
DIRECTLY CONFRONTED VLADIMIR
PUTIN ABOUT HIS BELIEF THAT
RUSSIAN GENERALS ARE MISMANAGING